[Music]
all right
see you later oh oh oh
my God
because you're at a Podium Rossi I just
figured you were taking the stand I did
feel like I should but it is a Drew
Barrymore show take it away Dee come on
actually it's it's the Drew uh X the
talk show yes it is
true we are all one big happy family but
we are about to change that because it's
game time okay yeah when it comes to
games everything changes it's Drew's
game day
all right
crash in here and you're all you're all
about to go head to head in a game of
taboo
[Applause]
close to Pictionary the best game ever
uh-huh and we take games very seriously
here Drew all right so there are high
stakes and here's how it works we split
our teams into two on the left we have
drew Akbar and Amanda and
and on the right we have Cheryl Jerry
and Natalie all right
well you all know how taboo works one
person will try to get their teammates
to guess a word on a card but there are
five taboo words that they cannot say
and if they do say I'm gonna go like
this
which I love doing all right
and they move on to the next card and if
you're stuck you can skip all right you
get one minute one minute to guess as
many words as you can and the women
winning team gets this amazing Drew's
game day trophy right here
look at that and audience you're
involved as well you folks over here you
get a prize if Drew's team wins
you get a prize if Cheryl's team wins
we drew straws backstage see who goes
first and Akbar you're up
you're gonna stand right here all right
let's get your cards ready you have uh
one minute on the clock okay ready get
set go
um
um uh it's all it's on my my my my uh no
no but then
in Seattle somewhere big Seahawks
big dude with a lot of flowy things
coming from the body
Starbucks no no no but but
um okay
[Applause]
um uh you can find about your DNA on
this uh ancestry.com okay I'll take it
all right I don't know what that is okay
um you know
oral hygiene you have to brush your
teeth but whipping toothbrush okay and
then um uh you take a hot knife
and then uh and you do you choose
get behind things
[Applause]
come on
right over here
one minute on the clock and You Begin
now
not summer
okay next one next one
wow
[Applause]
yeah
okay
it is a very close game five to six we
have one more round of taboo left come
out come back to find out who will be
our champion
[Applause]
[Music]